Bangladesh is the only country with an
Islamic majority whose president is a
woman.
Her name is Shankar on ads.
This is not a literal example.
We're talking about the third biggest
Muslim country with more than 160
million inhabitants.
Nonetheless,
there is one Bangladeshi,
even more famous than shake Asina.
This is Mohammed,
you know,
sees the Nobel Peace Prize winner as
well as the inventor of micro credits is
also from Bangalore
Dash.
This is surprising given that in this
country,
only at one out of every three citizens
has a bank accounts.
It's like Bangladesh is one of the
fastest growing economies of the last
few years.
They have reduced poverty faster than
anyone else and they are also the
world's second largest textile
manufacturer,
only surpassed by China.
But despite all of that,
most of the Bangladeshi people still
keep them money at home.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
why is this,
what exactly is going on in Bangladesh
that causes people not to trust the
bank?
Well,
the answer to this,
well,
it's religion.
According to Islam.
Lending money with interest is a sin and
90 percent of the Bangladeshi people are
Muslim,
but wait just a minute here because
things are changing in the last few
decades,
Muslim countries have created a system
that allows saving and lending money,
which also meets that Islamic
principles.
Yes,
dear viewer.
We are talking of course about Islamic
banking,
a phenomenon that is becoming more and
more important in Bangladesh,
and you might think that this is great
news for the governments of shakers
scene of rice.
Well,
in fact,
the opposite is actually true.
Islami back Bangladesh is most watched
bankers,
so now the question becomes why does the
government of Bangladesh distrust
Islamic banking?
And it's more importantly,
what role might Islamic banking having
the future of Bangladesh?
Well,
today we're going to answer those
questions,
but before we do,
let's answer the most important question
of all Islamic banking all about.
Okay,
so imagine we have a thousand American
dollars and they're just sitting in a
savings accounts are western bank can
give you an interest rate of say,
three percent.
Now unsure.
Many of you have wondered,
well,
how is it possible that a bank just
gives us money for money that is simply
sitting in it,
but where's the profit here?
Well,
the truth is that that a thousand
dollars,
it's not just staying in the bank safe.
Instead they use that money to lend to
companies and individuals.
Those lanes,
they simply have a higher interest rate
so the bank makes money and gives us
little sheriff that profits.
This is the basic mechanism of the
entire system of western
banking.
Now obviously this carries some degree
of risk because the bank can lose the
money,
but depending on the country we live in,
the is forced by law to keep a small
percentage of that $1,000,
that percentage,
it cannot be humans and it's schools.
The cash ratio.
Now,
according to Sharia law,
this system is sinful because lending
money with interest is seen as unfair.
Of course,
there is no problem with keeping your
client's money,
but you simply can't lend it to anyone
in economic jargon.
This means that Sharia law demands a 100
percent cash ratio.
So this in summary,
is the way that Islamic banks work,
and I love you wondering,
well,
why don't exactly is the business here?
Well,
mainly Islamic banks will make money by
two means.
First,
the banks charge their clients
commissions for keeping the money.
So instead of giving you an interest
rate,
Islamic banks can only give you a little
symbolic presence.
This president,
it's called the hip Bob.
Another business practice that is
allowed by Sharia law is adding over
costs.
For example,
let's say we buy a house with an Islamic
bank.
In this case,
the bank will buy the house for us and
then sell it to us at a higher price.
And this price is called the mercer
rocket runs.
We can pay for it in installments.
If for whatever reason we can't compete
the payments,
the bank will sell the house on the
market.
If they do get some profit from the
selling weed,
the clients can take a share of the
profits.
But wait just a minute here because this
is not the end of the story.
The current bands,
banks from investing in what they
considered dirty businesses such as
tobacco weapons or productive.
There's even a special index.
The Dow Jones Islamic markets has 1400
companies from the New York stock market
where Islamic banks can invest.
As you can imagine,
these things are becoming really
successful in several Muslim countries,
but well in Bangladesh,
they are absolutely kicking off.
Islamic banking is growing rapidly in
Bangladesh with a market share of about
20 percent.
Do they vent already?
AIDS banks have this kind of Bangladesh,
even Western banks like Citi on starting
to offer banking services for those who
demand them in a country where brides
are a thing everywhere Islamic banks are
famous for their transparency and good
practices.
Islamic banks for instance,
a famous of having nothing to do with
the Bangladeshi government,
so if you want to get a loan from an
Islamic Bank,
you have to demonstrate the you are a
reliable clients willing to pay back
your debts,
but hold on a minute here because well
things they are not as good as they
might seem for these banks.
Good Bank,
bad bank,
Islamic banking arrived in Bangladesh in
1983 when some Saudi and Kuwaiti hedge
funds decided to create the Islamic
Bank.
This bank played a crucial role in
turning an agricultural country into the
textile powerhouse that it is today.
Yeah.
Today clothes make up 80 percent of
Bangladeshi exports and Islamic Bank is
the biggest bank in the country.
Nonetheless,
the growth of Islamic banking in the
country is not clear enough.
Talk about our central bank is not
giving new Islamic banking licenses.
Even those western banks that once to
give Islamic banking services must wait.
They clean.
They need to create a brand new
regulations on the matter of Islamic
banking.
Meanwhile,
the governments of shake and CIENA has
send inspectors to the Islamic bank
officers and they are surveying all of
their movements.
Government initiates a coo at
Bangladesh.
Has biggest bank board members receive a
visit from military intelligence?
Yes.
So now you might wonder what is wrong
with the Islamic banks and the
governments?
Well,
shake a scene of claims that they are
financing terrorism.
As we explained in another video,
Islamic terrorism is becoming a real
threat to the country and many people
think some of these banks might be
financing terrorist groups.
However,
there are several reasons to make us
believe that at the end of the day,
this is nothing but a power struggle
shake us.
He loves to take things under her
control and the fact that the biggest
bank in the country sympathizes with the
proposals of the opposition party
certainly does not help.
This is why on January 2017 has seen an
interview,
interviewed the Islamic Bank and change
the board of managers by her own son.
Since then,
loans have skyrocketed.
The Bangladesh Central Bank itself has
warned that some of these loans are too
risky.
Meanwhile,
both Saudi and Qac hedge funds that
created the bank 35 years ago and now
taking back their money,
they simply don't think it is safe
anymore,
but wait just a minute because this is
not the first time that shake his senior
is trying to control the financial
industry in her.
You want the guy we mentioned at the
beginning,
Muhammad Yunus.
Well,
he is in.
Has Seen as cross as to in the year 2006
after some terrorist attacks,
the Bangladeshi army organized acute
Atar and created a technocratic
governments.
Back then,
Muhammad Yunus was a favorite
candidates.
Do you lead that government in the end
though?
That didn't happen,
but Hasina learned a vital lesson.
Beware of the bankers.
Sometimes they like to get involved in
politics.
This is why has seen his first priority
after taking position in 2008 was to
take care of Eunice.
First of all,
she forced him to resign as the chairman
of his own bag,
the grommet.
Of course,
some of our claims were true and make no
mistake.
Muhammad Yunus is not a perfect guy,
but we're going to talk about this in
another video,
but as if making him resigned was not
enough.
Has also started a campaign to diminish
his image in Bangladeshi society.
No Nobel
laureate,
Eunice Got Hillary Clinton to stop web
funding for Padma says Hasina.
In other words,
shake us.
He knows how to beat her political
enemies.
First it was eunice,
now it's the Islamic Bank.
So the question is now,
do you think there is an actual
connection between Islamic banks and
terrorism for.
Is this just an excuse made on by shake
Asina in order to keep the finance
industry under control?
And shouldn't Bangladesh allow Islamic
banks?
Do you operate in the country without
restrictions?
Well,
please leave your comments in the
comment section below.
Also visit our friends at the reconsider
media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but I'll not mine.
Also check out my other channel
biographics.
We do long form biographies of people
from history as well as the present day.
And if you liked this video,
please do hit like and subscribe because
we put out brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.